that more facial other than you know I
don't know it's possible I have more
facial hair than both of you why don't
you have more pubic hair than us
hello I am Ted I am Jerry
no I'm Heisenberg welcome two reasons to
see where we give you reasons to see
hang out with this racist all right
Pussycats let's talk about this movie
honestly I was low light now I did like
it a lot like as a standalone film I
thought it was good but as a Godzilla
movie I was like that's how a lot of the
old gods I remember renting those as a
can and being like these people sure
have been talking for an hour I guess
character-wise story wise it wasn't what
I thought Bryan Cranston is only in the
beginning and that was really sad it
made sense why they had the story
continue the way they did I was so
invested in his performance and he likes
mini crying like I know his performance
is amazing made me feel things for these
characters his death to me wasn't I was
like waiting for Roy and it should have
been in my opinion yeah because he was
like the best actor in that film really
I feel like I would feel a lot more but
they just kind of went okay now it's
back to the action his character spent
15 years doing this and then he you know
he falls off and then he has a couple
lines when he's in the journey and then
they just serve him up oh my god I was
like they're not gonna come off they
can't do it and then they do and I was
like of course yeah I thought he should
have had a more dramatic death yeah if
you're gonna kill him walk better Lee I
wanted him to see Godzilla basically
justice was served all around for the
town and it would have been for his wife
and he didn't even get to see that which
was really sad I have a feeling that
everything you guys don't like about
this movie is everything I think what
did I tell you this movie was there were
so many surprises to me and like Grant
and I stayed away from so much of the
promotional stuff but it doesn't even
see it seems like they were able to hide
all this stuff pretty well yeah
regardless I was like they're not gonna
oh my god
they did yeah like they really killed
him ah it's like yeah in a popcorn sort
of way it would have been rewarding for
him to conquer the day and and see this
through but that's not how it works you
know it passes on to his son yeah I mean
his redemption is is is people
vindication it's like I am NOT crazy and
y'all know it now what yeah I know I
thought even my son who thinks I'm crazy
and should move on
I can't believe me yeah I kept thinking
about all the things he said in the
beginning and how much his son you know
developed mentally about the whole
entire thing and the actor that played
the kid was was very great he's got both
puppy-dog eyes he's very muscular and it
takes me time to get used to that
I disagree with a lot of these
statements I didn't find anything
surprising in the snow was surprising I
was like that was all good like I
thought it was a right honestly thought
it was a really good film I didn't
realize there were gonna be whole other
monsters flying one but I was like oh
he's just gonna battle something at the
end I didn't know that was what its
gonna focus on I loved though that it
was all about how they were just trying
to reproduce because I don't know I just
thought that that was more realistic but
they just want to mess [ __ ] up
I've predicted that in the end muta was
going to eat the the bomb and then
explode that's how I thought you know it
was gonna die so I was shocked when
because those rips open its mouth and
then oh I was cool I was waiting for
that moment I knew there would be some
sort of moment that would kind of redeem
how kind of slow I mean I wasn't slow
but it was just a little long with the
talking I thought the character
development was really good half-hour
yeah but then after that it became more
about the adventure and more about
what's going on which makes sense it all
makes sense and even Bryan Cranston down
I get like oh yeah this is now it's
gonna be Aaron taylor-johnson story his
Redemption now especially if I always
probably got some motivation because
he's like man I really feel bad about
what I did with my dad easier so yeah I
thought her and I didn't have a hard
time adjusting Aaron taylor-johnson I
thought he was great in the role I
thought Elizabeth Olsen was good like at
the end when they reunite I almost cried
actually yeah they got pride I thought
that was a really beautiful moment to
everything about her Taylor Johnson was
it was awesome to me in this film
interact with a Japanese good it's like
you could yeah to be a good Japanese dad
did when you won catch the parallel of
him in Godzilla at all because I thought
I thought it was frickin brilliant that
you know remember when they just looked
at each other that moment when Godzilla
just looked at him and then the smoke
cleared and he was just like whoa and
then after that they both collapsed at
the same time at the very end and they
both kind of like woke up I don't know I
just thought that that was cool cuz they
were both heroes in a way in a way no
they were both war heroes but I mean
together in a way that train scene is
like these little things that it puts
its characters into and sort of moves
the plot along with I thought really
interesting and clever and there are so
many really great transitions the music
I loved the music was so great and let
me just tell you this one moment it's
it's surprising when it music that good
usually you don't notice it but there
are some moments that you notice it and
it hits you and from me that was when
Godzilla turned around I think he was in
like Chinatown or whatever when this
happened and he turned around all the
music just stopped and all the noise
just stopped and it was just like piano
like one piano key asleep ding-ding and
they just turned on and that was so
intense well the score itself is very
retro very it's very brassy they use a
lot of instruments you just don't hear
in these kinds of movies anymore one of
the more you know reminiscent of older
movies you know elements that this has I
mean yeah I would have loved to see more
of Godzilla and I thought that they
focus a little more on you know the
Muto's more and there was some parts I
was like I don't like looking at them I
would rather look at Godzilla and you
know there's some parts room like I
don't care about that yeah I mean in
this day and age of getting so much of
what we want and I really didn't mind
it's making me want and giving me a
little bit spirit it just definitely
wasn't what I expected
I love how gods all just kind of took a
nap at the end like a long like it's not
it's not a panther ii sort of movie and
i really liked that we got more of the
moutains because it's like you get to
know your enemy you get to know that the
worst of all evils first and then you
know I think what makes the best movies
are when the villains are the best I
think this one even though they don't
talk or anything you know they're just
these huge creatures they they did [ __ ]
some [ __ ] up and Godzilla had to put him
straight I thought that was powerful I
still again would have loved to see more
of Godzilla but maybe that maybe they
did that on purpose for a sequel or
something I don't know I mean we don't
have the atomic urine now but it is sort
of that atomic era dready paranoia
monster movie there are other monsters
yes they realize halfway through there's
a female and they're actually like
calling to each other to mate and she
has this huge sack of like babies and
it's really gross there was one thing
though where they were like nuzzling and
i was like that's cute
but wait i'm not supposed to like you
guys because you're villains that was
they're just animal like that there are
only villains in the sensitivity is
destroying our world I didn't think of
them as like evil per se I just knew
that they were going when you're
building some Legos and your dog just
walks right through because they wanted
to get to it Street I like what they did
with a Godzilla being the hero actually
because he did feel like a hero by the
end of this in the story I mean when he
kills the the mute oh by opening his
mouth and then bird feeding him that was
pretty cool you know when you do think
he's dead and I like how the news
reports were saying like he's the hero
and then when he wakes up he doesn't
start thrashing the city he actually
makes a pretty decent walk back to the
ocean yeah anyone he does this ladder or
like you're welcome and then goes back
into the sea well that's sort of a
byproduct of a lot of this subsequent
Godzilla films like after the original
one is that Godzilla over time became
less monster attack in the city and more
like the defender against other giant
ones for the purpose one of the moments
I really liked a lot was when Ken
Watanabe was watching the Bryan Cranston
interrogation scene that moment where he
could see him kind of like understanding
what was going on and see that this guy
I might be telling the truth about
something and that he might know more
than they know when the whole disaster
happened when the Mutai broke out that
he was right there to be like yeah I
want those two
my team yeah and it was very smart is
smart and it was also like that level of
compassion and understanding that he has
like a big theme of this movie is really
family yeah and like even when I just I
really loved almost every character
moment in it like when Aaron
taylor-johnson comes home from the milk
and then he see him with his family and
everything and he's got this whole like
[ __ ] up past but they didn't like ant
built the whole haunted pass thing yeah
it was like yeah you can isn't safe to
assume this guy has the heart to pass
well yeah it's like they play it as the
facts of these characters lions not like
oh my god
this movie and this story could have
been really cheesy but it wasn't so I
applaud them for that because that takes
then when they go into the quarantine
zone - I just love the design of it
really glad that's that struck me yeah
yeah the whole movie stay true to what
people are really like like there is
nothing in it that I found to be cliche
about any of the characters at all I
really like the interaction between
elizabeth olsen and aaron taylor-johnson
- I thought it was really uh you know
they have a really good chemistry a to
begin with but the way that whole
relationship kind of just evolves he
just came back from the army and now
he's in Japan because his dad [ __ ] up
and so he's he's just on this mission
for redemption the whole time they're
just every step he takes it's all about
it's all about family it's all about
going back to family and then he hops on
that train and that whole turned that
whole bridge sequence was just so
beautifully done